actualités politiques de ce weekend
marqué notamment par une réunion des
socialistes antinhub du côté de
Montpellier où on va aller justement
retrouver Olivier Biscaye bonjour
Olivier merci
d'être avec nous directeur de la
rédaction du Midi Libre et Olivier ce
weekend du côté de Montpellier il y
avait les journées de refondation
refondation c'est la branche des
socialistes Antigny
oui ambiance de travail ambiance studio
à Montpellier ils étaient tous là autour
de refondation Nicolas Mayer Rossignol
le numéro 2 du Parti socialiste maire de
Rouen nid d'algo Michael Delafosse le
maire de Montpellier Carol Delga la
présidente de la région Occitanie il y a
même Benoît Hamon ancien candidat
socialiste à la présidentielle de 2017
sur la photo de famille vous le voyez
sur sur l'Antarctique pour bien montrer
qu'on était Unis ici dans cette dans ce
groupement socialiste de gauche anti-up
anti LFI parce que c'est bien ça
évidemment la ligne rouge de ce week-end
on a bien voulu montrer qu'on était très
différent de LFI de Jean-Luc Mélenchon
et qu'on était unis autour d'une idée
d'un certain nombre de valeurs on a
d'ailleurs beaucoup parlé d'Europe de
sécurité d'immigration de restauration
d'autorité de l'État et évidemment de
campagne présidentielle vous vous en
doutez entre le vendredi soir et
l'apéritif ou 400 militants étaient
réunis et les habitables rondes et les
ateliers de travail on s'en doute un peu
que ça a parlé de 2027 il y a déjà un
favori
oui ils sont si nombreux si vous saviez
Oriane évidemment il y a Bernard
Cazeneuve alors qu'il était fils et non
pas là mais qui était en visioconférence
pour expliquer qu'il fallait évidemment
s'unir il se il réunira d'ailleurs ces
troupes le 10 juin pour la première
réunion publique nationale de sa
convention le mouvement alors on parle
de Michael de la folle dans les allées
chez lui donc évidemment on considère
qu'il pourrait être un jour un candidat
naturel pour la présidentielle mais on
parle surtout de Carole Delta elle donne
d'ailleurs ce matin une interview dans
dans le Figaro Yves Treillard dans
lequel elle explique qu'il faut
évidemment s'unir pour les prochaines
échéances les Européennes de 2024 la
présidentielle à la question serait vous
candidate ou elle considère qu'elle est
lucide qu'il faut attendre que c'était
en 2025 qu'il faudra probablement se
positionner donc tout ceci est en train
de mijoter de travailler tout le monde
considérait évidemment qu'il faut du
temps pour se préparer travailler
d'abord avant de désigner un candidat
unique merci
Le Figaro Midi Libre il est fort
évidemment pour tout savoir de ce qui
s'est passé du côté de Montpellier
c'est-à-dire dans Midi Libre et on
regarde la une
regarde la ligne du Midi Libre se garer
à la plage combien ça coûte 7 à la Une
de votre journal merci beaucoup Olivier
merci d'avoir été avec nous pour nous
parler de cette actualité on disait
évidemment Olivier il a très bien dit
une interview Carole delgas matin dans
Le Figaro est-ce que la gauche continue
les socialistes continuent peuvent se
structurer derrière elle est-ce qu'ils
peuvent se structurer tout court déjà
non parce que je pense que c'est enfin
c'est c'est une si vous voulez le
problème de cette gauche continue comme
vous le dites elle est en quête d'une
identité elle est en quête d'une
personnalité elle est en quête d'un
espace alors l'espace celle-là moi je
j'estime que justement elle a elle a
raison de à ceux qui sont de ceux qui se
revendiquent de cette sensibilité
en raison de croire en leur chance parce
que il y a un espace évident entre la
majorité présidentielle qui est de plus
en plus à droite on va pas se leurrer et
puis laupes qui est pour beaucoup et
bien une gauche trop radicale
donc il y a un espace mais le problème
c'est qu'il y a une bouteillage entre
Bernard Cazeneuve Carol Delga Anne
Hidalgo alors un Hidalgo compte tenu de
son score en 2000 en
2022 je pense que
les autres
sont un peu dans une course à l'échalote
qui va être qui va être compliqué mais
sinon il y a un espace il y a un espace
de guerre des égaux bien sûr est-ce que
ce qui s'est passé ce week-end à
Montpellier ça veut dire que le PS
n'arrive pas à tourner la page du
congrès de Marseille et n'arrive pas à
sortir de ses divisions Benjamin oui
mais c'est plus profond que ça en
réalité c'est à dire que aujourd'hui il
y a deux éléments d'abord vous avez une
vraie fracture entre d'un côté une
grande partie des élus locaux donc il
faut bien comprendre rendu compte que
quand vous faites une élection locale et
qu'il y a beaucoup d'abstention vous
êtes en règle générale élue par les élus
centrices par les électeurs centristes
et donc évidemment quand vous avez
Jean-Luc Mélenchon quand vous êtes dans
une stratégie nuque c'est compliqué
parce que il faut assumer une position
beaucoup plus radicale qui même si
individuellement vous ne la prenez pas
et ben vous colle à la peau et donc
beaucoup d'élus locaux et vous remarquez
que beaucoup de ceux qui sont en rupture
de banque sont plutôt des élus locaux et
ben la Nupe est une stratégie un peu
dangereuse de l'autre côté le groupe
parlementaire et Ben et sur une ligne
très très différente parce qu'en réalité
si demain vous avez une explosion de la
nuque qui d'abord une alliance entre des
parties de gauche et ben Emmanuel Macron
a tout intérêt à dissoudre la plupart
des circonscriptions qui ont été gagnées
par la nuque ne sont des fiefs que grâce
à l'alliance qui a été la nuque c'est un
effet du mode de scrutin en réalité plus
vous avez une alliance large plus les
effets mécaniques du mode de scrutin
même si vous faites moins de voix ce qui
était le cas en 2022 par rapport à 2017
et bien vous donne plus de députés donc
là il y a un effet un hiatus stratégique
et ensuite pour 2027 je rejoins Yves
mais avec des limites c'est à dire que
oui il y a un espace politique
aujourd'hui cet espace social-démocrate
structurellement il pâle il pèse 10% des
lectorats environ cet espace
social-démocrate aujourd'hui il est en
train d'être dégagé partiellement par
Emmanuel Macron et en 2027 et ben c'est
un espace qui a priori souvent si on a
une candidature qui n'est pas celle
d'Emmanuel Macron et qui est orienté
plus à droite pour le centre et bah
c'est un espace politique qui est en
jachère et ça ne pèse que 10% la
question c'est comment est-ce que vous
les tendez la stratégie Emmanuel Macron
c'est de dire on va chercher au centre
droit d'accord mais aucun de ceux qui
étaient à Montpellier ne prônent une
union des centres ou alors vous allez
chercher cet espace politique à gauche
en espérant que il y a un report
automatique de voix le problème c'est
qu'on voit qu'aujourd'hui le point
d'équilibre partisan de la gauche est
beaucoup plus à gauche que les gens qui
étaient à Montpellier et donc arriver à
aller chercher une fine et les lecteurs
Mélenchon pour voter pour Bernard
Cazeneuve pourquoi pas mais c'est une
gageure et c'est vrai que la stratégie
d'opposition vis-à-vis de la nu-pla
dessus risque aussi de laisser des
traces donc c'est pas une impasse
stratégique mais à ce stade là c'est ton
corps embryonnaire Clémentine Notin hier
elle était au Grand Jury Elcy RTL le
Figaro ivre et elle disait que si la
gauche n'a pas disparu c'est grâce à
l'accord de la Nupe elle disait en
Italie la gauche a disparu parce que
l'Union s'est faite autour du pôle le
plus modéré est-ce qu'elle dit vrai
oui d'une certaine façon c'est vrai que
c'est un discours audible parce que
le si vous voulez ce qui a tout détruit
et ce qui a quand même bouleversé le
paysage politique c'est le
positionnement de Manuel Macron qui
depuis le début
ces positionner en étant et de gauche et
de droite c'est c'est pas ni de gauche
ni de droite c'est et de gauche et de
droite donc c'est ça qui a quand même
pas mal bouleversé la donne et ce qui a
renvoyé aux extrêmes d'une certaine
façon et la droite et la gauche et donc
c'est pour ça qu'aujourd'hui et bien le
Parti socialiste d'une part et les
républicains d'autre part ont été
réduits à la portion congrue parce que
Emmanuel Macron est allé chasser sur ces
terres-là Emmanuel Macron si vous voulez
il va de pour faire vite si on prend le
les repères anciens il va de Manuel
Valls à
la RPR classique donc on en est là
aujourd'hui et c'est pour ça que vous
avez ces deux extrêmes à chaque à chaque
à chaque pôle et c'est le fait que
l'accord se fasse autour de LFx qui a
sauvé la gauche comme le dit Clémentine
autant c'est l'accord par nature encore
une fois c'est l'effet du mode de
scrutin quand vous partez en or dispersé
vous arrivez avec des résultats qui sont
mauvais quand vous vous unissez même si
l'Union c'est un peu celle de la carpe
et du lapin et ben vous arrivez à faire
des choses importantes mais il y a un
autre facteur c'est l'union tout court
ou l'union avec comme Paul central et la
fille est-ce que c'est l'union s'était
faite autour du PS ça aurait été la même
chose et c'est un autre facteur qui
n'est pas tant à les filles que quand
même Jean-Luc Mélenchon aujourd'hui vous
avez trois personnalités politiques qui
sont reconnues de manière claire par
l'opinion Emmanuel Macron Marine Le Pen
et Jean-Luc Mélenchon on peut reprocher
beaucoup de choses à Jean-Luc Mélenchon
mais sa capacité à faire campagne sa
capacité son charisme et sa possibilité
à chaque présidentielle de commencer à
10 et à finir à 20 et quand même quelque
chose qu'il faut lui reconnaître et l'un
à la fois des points d'incertitude pour
la gauche et pour cette gauche là
peut-être un point d'espoir c'est que
quel avenir pour le mélenchonisme que il
décide de ne pas se représenter ou qu'il
soit évincé par elle ETI si demain vous
n'avez pas Mélenchon cette capacité de
tractage et beaucoup peu moins forte
mais tant que Jean-Luc Mélenchon est là
pour des raisons je dirais liées à la
Cinquième République qui reste un régime
bonapartiste même si Jean-Luc Mélenchon
s'en garde et bien il est le leader qui
fait que derrière le leader ce groupe
les électeurs et maintenant que Jean-Luc
Mélenchon est là c'est vrai que l'espace
politique à gauche et quand même très
restreint très limité en même temps on
peut se demander si cette gauche
continue n'est pas en train d'exploiter
aujourd'hui une forme d'affaiblissement
de Jean-Luc Mélenchon sur cette année
pose présidentielle c'est-à-dire qu'il
était sorti de la présidentielle très
populaire et il y a une forme
d'affaiblissement dans l'opinion
publique notamment avec l'affaire
catenens sont son rôle qu'elle a essayé
de jouer dans la mobilisation contre la
réforme des retraites ou finalement il
s'est mis à dos pour un leader de gauche
qui était quand même assez étonnant il
s'est mis quand même ado les syndicats
enfin son dialogue avec les syndicats ne
passaient pas il y a également eu des
divisions en interne au sein de la
France insoumise sur sa propre stratégie
la propre stratégie insoumise à mener à
l'Assemblée nationale donc même au sein
de la France insoumise il y a des
divisions c'est peut-être aussi ce que
c'est d'exploiter ces socialistes
dissidents ouais mais souvenez-vous 2018
en 2018 à la fois les perquisitions et
en même temps il y a les fameuses
marches pour le port d'achat acceptera
tout ça explose et on a un Jean-Luc
Mélenchon qui apparaît comme étant
excusez-moi l'expression mais grillé
mais la capacité à faire campagne encore
une fois resouler ça je rappelle que il
était pas évident qu'il soit devant
Yannick Jadot et une dalgo quelques mois
avant la présidence donc il y a malgré
tout ça le deuxième élément et ben c'est
que même si vous avez des perturbations
à la fi Jean-Luc Mélenchon c'est assez
bien organisé son parti à l'ancienne
pour savoir que aujourd'hui il tient les
finances et le groupe ce qui en fait au
sein d'un truc aussi nébuleux que la fi
donne le fond de ce qui fait l'intérêt
pour lui de la France insoumise vous
parlez de la mobilisation contre la
réforme des retraites elle aura lieu
demain jeudi elle vote de la proposition
de loi du groupe lot Yves hier ont été
publiés les décrets qui reportent l'âge
légal de départ à 64 ans est-ce que la
gauche joue gros cette semaine est-ce
que
la PPL lotte ne passe pas ce serait une
défaite pour la gauche
par définition une défaite pour la
gauche puisque elle n'a pas réussi son
coup on va dire ça comme ça pour pas les
vulgairement maintenant il va falloir et
c'est là où c'est très intéressant c'est
que on va voir si elle arrive à
surmonter cette échec et c'est là où on
va voir peut-être qu'il y a 2 gauche qui
émergent de gauche je parle sur le fond
sur le fond
idéologique d'une part la gauche
identitaire et d'autre part la gauche
du travail et
ces deux gauches qui avaient été
identifiées un peu par Fabien Roussel
que reprend d'ailleurs
un des concurrents de Jean-Luc Mélenchon
à l'intérieur de de LFI en l'occurrence
François Ruffin et parce que on va
passer à d'autres sujets qui sont les
sujets les sujets économiques
vraisemblablement mais aussi le sujet de
l'immigration on va voir comment se
positionne et bien cette cette gauche
est-ce qu'elle ne risque pas justement
et bien de se fracturer à l'occasion de
ces futurs débats ça veut dire que la
prendre des retraites a réussi à l’unir
et que une fois passé la séquence
rapporte des retraites si la page est
tournée la réforme des retraites elle a
fait en sorte elle a elle a elle a
surtout je dirais
on a surtout entendu la gauche
identitaire cette cette effet on va on
va voir si maintenant les réunions
mais on a vu que
il y a quand même des premières factures
fractures qui se sont qui se sont fait
jour on va voir comment ça se passe
maintenant ça veut dire que le plus
compliqué est à venir ah oui parce que
derrière vous avez comme les Européennes
et les européennes c'est le grand enjeu
pourquoi bah parce qu'en réalité les
parties qui ont été les parties les
parties plutôt marginalisées dans le
cadre des accords de la nuque hein je
pense notamment au Europe Écologie Les
Verts ou le Parti socialiste peuvent
compter sur un bon score pas parce que
aujourd'hui ils auraient
fondamentalement le vent en poupe mais
parce que c'est leurs élections c'est en
règle générale leur thème et puis qui
plus est c'est l'heure électorat qui est
mobilisé il y a une surprésentation des
CSP plus etc ce sont les élections pour
Europe Écologie Les Verts si jamais
Europe Écologie Les Verts est devant la
France insoumise il y a une évolution du
rapport de force dans quelle mesure la
France insoumise peut accepter de revoir
le rapport de force en sa défaveur après
des élections européennes une fois que
vous avez dit ça vous comprenez pourquoi
les filles plaid pour une liste unique
et que de l'autre côté les Verts
évidemment profondément n'en veulent pas
et la question derrière c'est une fois
que vous êtes tiré dans les pattes
pendant des mois lors de la campagne
parce que lorsque vous faites campagne
vous allez pas chercher les lecteurs si
vous êtes vert ou à les filles vous
allez pas chercher le lecteur RN tapez
sur le RN mais vous allez chercher le
lecteurs qui balance entre LFI donc vont
votre vraie adversaire c'est pas celui
qui est à l'opposé c'est les parties à
proximité et donc ça va être une foire
d'empoigne pour ces parties là arriver à
tenir ensemble au sein de la nuque parce
que sinon encore une fois il y a tout
intérêt pour Emmanuel Macron a dissoudre
ça va être extrêmement compliqué donc il
y a un enjeu de repositionnement de la
nuque il y a un enjeu de est-ce que la
nuque tient et ça ça va être une vraie
vraie vraie période de turbulation oui
une question de survie de la nuque même
en effet
avec une élection qui est l'élection
européenne où là il y a des vrais
divergences il y a des pays enfin des
partis qui sont trop européens et vous
avez d'autres parties qui sont quand
même beaucoup plus réceptiques c'est le
cas de la France insoumise
c'est le cas du Parti communiste alors
que le Parti socialiste est divisé sur
la question lui-même déjà il pèse pas
lourd mais il y a des divisions et puis
Europe écologie des Verts qui est très
pro-européen et pour le pour ce parti
cette élection c'est quasiment
l'élection reine c'est l'élection où ils
se font à chaque fois valoir et où il
peuvent être assurés s'ils font une
bonne campagne de récolter pas mal de
voix oui il prenait il y a marine
Tondelier a donné un une interview dans
le média en ligne le vent se lève
récemment ou à l'explique il faut
dépasser le l'État nation il faut la
dépasser il faut le dépasser par les
régions et par l'Europe là vous êtes
totalement à l'opposé de ce que peut
dire un Jean-Luc Mélenchon comment
est-ce que vous arrivez à faire
programme comment là-dessus évidemment
il y a des choses dans l'accord de la
nuque mais on va pas se mentir ce sont
des points qui sont des points
aujourd'hui extrêmement crispants et
donc la liste commune aurait peu de
chances de donner une signification
forte à ce que veut la nuque et la
gauche pour l'Europe mais de l'autre
côté encore une fois bah les listes
séparées c'est très très probablement
très difficile à dépasser merci merci
Benjamin merci évidemment l'occasion de
reparler de tout ça on continue de
parler de la réforme des retraites elle
a une de nos quotidiens régionaux
[Musique]
et Alex à la Une de La Dépêche la
réforme des retraites et une nouvelle
semaine sous tension effectivement les
syndicats appellent à une 14e journée de
mobilisation contre la réforme des
retraites une manifestation qui a pour
but notamment de soutenir la proposition
de loi d'abrogation de la réforme
déposer par le groupe lot à l'Assemblée
nationale et qui sera discuté jeudi dans
l'émission enfin ça c'est si c'est la
présidente de l'Assemblée c'est sauf si
la présidente de l'Assemblée nationale
décide de déclarer irrecevable cette
mesure d'abrogation de la retraite à 64
ans noter aussi que les premiers décrets
d'application de la réforme ont été déjà
publiés au Journal officiel objectif
pour Emmanuel Macron appliqué sa réforme
des retraites dès le premier septembre
et Alex beaucoup d'indignation après
l'agression du petit Kenzo un enfant
malade molesté samedi soir par des
supporters de laçage action de 8 ans
atteint d'un cancer du cerveau fan de
l'Olympique de Marseille il était invité
samedi soir au match Ajaccio Marseille
au stade François Coty dans la ville
corse alors naturellement il avait
enfilé son maillot Jeux olympiques de
Marseille et c'est alors qu'une
quinzaine de supporters d'Ajaccio ont
asséné à des coups de poing à son papa
et ont poussé l'enfant qui s'est cogné
le visage une enquête a été ouverte par
le parquet d'Ajaccio pour violence en
réunion et dans cette soirée un
journaliste de France 3 Corse viastella
aussi été agressé mais cette fois-ci par
un supporter marseillais l'homme est en
garde à vue tous les détails de cette
affaire sont à lire dans corps ce matin
et puis la violence contre les élus se
poursuit malheureusement c'est à dire
dans les Dernières Nouvelles d'Alsace le
maire de la commune de manière en
Meurthe-et-Moselle a été roué de coup
par des jeunes qui avaient loué la salle
des fêtes du village pour un
anniversaire vers 2h30 du matin comme il
y avait du tapage nocturne le maire est
venu siffler à la fin de la fête il a
ensuite été tabassé par ces jeunes alors
heureusement que des riverains sont
intervenus pour le sauver le maire
Édouard Babel souffre actuellement de
contusion un homme de 18 ans et mineur
de 16 ans ont été placés en garde à vue
les difficultés des étudiants pour se
loger c'est la ligne du Télégramme c'est
un sujet sensible qui revient beaucoup
en ce moment dans l'actualité le du
logement va être très tendu pour les
étudiants il y a une forte demande la
démographie étudiante est en train de
s'accroître les jeunes travailleurs se
rabattent eux aussi vers la location car
l'accès à nos propriétés d'un logement
est de plus en plus difficile et puis de
l'autre côté l'offre de logements et
restreinte avec les nouvelles normes
énergétiques et une construction
insuffisante sans oublier l'inflation
une situation qui va donc au final
fragiliser un peu plus la population
étudiante
finir c'est la fin des championnats et
oui c'est la fin des championnats donc
elle a une de sud-ouest par exemple on
célèbre le club de rugby de Bordeaux
Bègles qui s'est qualifié hier en
demi-finale du Top 14 après sa victoire
contre les Lyonnais du loup elle a une
de presse océans le club de football de
Nantes et bien lui est passé tout près
du fiasco en ce maintenant Ligue 1 à la
dernière journée et puis le journal le
bien public lui célèbre le club de
handball de Dijon qui revient dans
l'élite du handball et qui est sacrée
champion de France de Pro League c'est
la deuxième division de handball
merci beaucoup Alex merci d'avoir été
avec nous merci
à tous de nous avoir suivis pour voir ou
revoir cette émission c'est sur notre
nouvelle plateforme public sénat.fr
prochain rendez-vous 18h Thomas Huc sens
publique et puis à 19h30 livre audition
publique audition publique avec marcéno
le ministre de l'Agriculture ce sera à
suivre et nous on se retrouve demain
avec Yannick Jadot notre invité très
bonne journée à demain
[Musique]